marié bonsoir vous avez été journaliste
pendant onze ans à france 3 est à tf1
s'est fait l'auteur de biographies de
géniale idée d'alain delon du commandant
cousteau et vous publié chez flammarion
ppda
voilà c'est un peu là la compil de la
face cachée de poivre d'arvor à
commencer par son nom d'ailleurs vous
raconter l'inauguration de la rue jean
d'arvor à reims en 2003 en présence du
maire de la ville et est en fait on
apprend les envois de bouquins que jean
d'arvor c'est le pseudonyme du grand
père de patrick poivre d'arvor qui
s'appelle jean baptiste je sais ça
d'hommes d'affaires qui s'était fait
notre cas où choo et qui pendant ses
heures de loisirs écrivait des poèmes
d'après ppda des poèmes surtout mystique
dédié à jeanne d'arc à l'électoral de
race et puis j'apprends effectivement au
fil des investigations qui décalait pas
que des poèmes mairie d'avrillé des
nouvelles de retour de dire polissonne
oui alors il a écrit là raymond folie la
paix chez les poules enfin tout un duo
de châtrices ces grains donc si on fait
d'arvor c'était un pseudonyme du grand
père tout à fait qu'il a que patrick
donc à récupérer au moment où il s'est
lancé dans le journalisme c'est à dire
au début des années 70 c'est fort quand
même d'être arrivé à faire nommer une
rue de ce nom d'arvor comme vous êtes au
sens de la vérité médiatique
française que vous avez l'influencent
qu'un monsieur poivre d'arvor on va
c'est vrai que conseil municipal s'est
laissé séduire par cette idée moi c'est
un sachant qu' une petite ruelle de
façon industrielle
reste près de là près du supermarché
cora donc en 2004 patrick poivre est
autorisé par le journal officiel à
s'appeler poivre d'arvor donc désormais
c'est son nom du logiciel erp qui
s'appelle maintenant giscard d'estaing
exactement ce qui est terrible aussi
enfin c'est vous qui dites ça dans votre
bouquin mais c'est que en fait patrick
poivre d'arvor a toujours dit que il
était le descendant d'un fameux
botaniste un aventurier d des épices qui
sera la pierre poivre qu'il faut ce
qu'il faut ce que le pauvre pierre grall
n'avait que deux filles alors bon une
fois qu'il a pris les doigts dans la
confiture il sait dire mais c'est
peut-être pas lui c'est de son frère bon
ce n'est pas non plus son frère bon ça
c'est c'est indiqué une des
caractéristiques de la façon de penser
de poivre qui était qu'elle toujours un
gros penchant pour la fabulation faut le
dire il se faisait passer pour le neveu
du prince rainier quelques années plus
tard à ses amis collégiens il est bon
oui je suis fille elle de saint-exupéry
et puis un peu plus tard effectivement
d'une l'adulte c'était ce fameux e puis
après il a jugé pas subventionner les
bouquins il ce qu'il avait trouvé un
aïeul du côté de jeanne d'arc alors je
pense qu'à ce rythme là dans deux ans il
va nous trouver quelqu'un du côté de la
pièce de jeu bon alors ça c'est cesser
c'est sympa je veux dire chez les poètes
chez les les les comédiens chez les
écrivains authentique qui n'est pas à
mon avis tout à fait c'est effectivement
plus inquiétant chez un homme qui dans
l'émission koh lanta former des millions
de français tous les soirs alors c'est
vrai qu'en lisant votre livre on
s'aperçoit que patrick poivre d'arvor
est obsédé par s'inventer des origines
il fait même un reportage aux seychelles
sur l'île poivre pepper island alors que
là je dis aux historiens sérieux
on lui a dit non c'est pas possible la
wii continue à entretenir cette légende
et beaucoup de juristes group sa et
continue à faire des papiers sur
l'ancêtre de pas très bon est ce qu'il
avait fait rêver sa vie ce qu'elle
venait de mettre en scène sa vie est ce
que je sais pas c'est un contexte une
réponse dans votre bouquin parce que on
apprend en fait que le père de patrick
poivre d'arvor
était engagé dans le 1er régiment de
france qui était un l'armée de vichy
quoi c'est un régiment pétainiste c'est
être un refus de ces vraies origines
vous pensez pas je pense non c'est plus
un choix qui vous ressemble à peu de ses
côtés c'est qu'ils sont emmerdés il
s'ennuyait durant son enfance
adolescence
papa qui dit représentants et ce sourire
de reims ou s'ennuyer franchement est ce
nous le dimanche et c'est vrai que bon
il s'est inventé une vie il a rêvé de
deux mondes fabuleux eudes d'ancêtres
aristocratique c'est possible et c'est
bon et je dis c'est très bien c'est vrai
que l'on a besoin enfants ou adolescents
d'enrichir sur l'imaginaire mais je dis
que c'est encore ça à l'âge adulte à mon
avis là ça devient pathologique
non je pense que sinon je pense que
c'est un refus je pense qu'en fait c'est
un refus de son père moi je pense que il
l'a dit d'ailleurs ici un soir il a dit
que finalement il mais pas tellement son
père quand son père rentrait de trois
semaines de tournée oui où il était sur
les routes pour placer des chaussures
dans des magasins il lui parlait à peine
je ne sais pas si il n'est pas son père
mais je pense que l'absence de son père
l'a fait souffrir ça c'est certain d'où
d'ailleurs ce transfert verve ce fameux
grand père pittoresque au caractère
entier près omniprésent et puis en plus
ce qui là qu'il a eu et cultivé qui
l'initié justement à l'écriture ou chose
de dur claude et ce goût du livre qui
est certain chez lui du der et il a un
goût sincère pour la littérature et pour
les livres même s'il crie pas très bien
il ya de ces bouquins qui mc bouquin je
sais pas je sais pas mais j'aime
beaucoup que ce bien clair voilà voilà
donc ça c'est un peu les scoops du
bouquin parce qu'après ce que vous
racontez sur ses enfants soient
télévision ces choses qu'on savait un
petit peu quand même nom bernard non je
n'ai pas ouais ça dépend aussi beaucoup
sur sur son métier de journaliste
effectivement sur c'est un dérapage
dérives très graves à mon sens vous
révéler quoi en fait sur la fère saddam
hussein par exemple jeune âge apporte
quelques éléments nouveaux concernant ce
fameux épisode du bébé l'irak oui alors
oui mais bon oui alors un rêve et qui
s'appelle florian lorient patrick poivre
d'arvor leur apporte en l'attendant dans
un sac est en fait vous dites alors ça
n'engage que vous n'etes pas déclassé en
fait que attali en fait quand il était à
matignon a intercepté une conversation
entre l'ambassadeur d'irak en france et
michèle cotta qu'à l'époque dirigé
l'information de tf1 et vous suggérez
très clairement en fait que c'est un que
c'est un coup monté que c'est une
opération de propagande en fait du
régime irakien je pense pas que le coup
était prémédité depuis la france qu'elle
ait été prémédité sur place
effectivement pour se faire un coup de
pub comme on dit ça c'est certain mais
il ya quelque chose de plus tragique que
ne plus pathétique bon même si c'est
anecdotique
c'est ensuite toute l'exploitation
médiatique de pda à propos de ses sept
enfants rentrée
il a rentré d'irak c'est bon qu'il a
accepté d'être le parrain de ce gamin
agen succès sur l'utilisation paris
match et que ces gamins a fini par
mourir vous savez dans un accident de
voiture malheureusement bon leur
nouvelle couverte de paris match le
chagrin ppda 1 par le sheikh des parents
mais sur un pda parce que je trouvais ça
un peu indécent et puis et puis
peut-être comportements pas très pas
très élégant de la part de pda l'égard
de ce gamin qui donc dont il était le
parrain bon et demande aux papas bon
alors je suppose qu'on ne part il
offrait des cadeaux noël ses adversaires
il ya oui ça il a toujours été présent
toujours jeu mais raté une date mais je
dis qu'est-ce qu'il offrait comme cadeau
à ce garçon ah ben à chaque fois c'était
que dégager de tf1 enfin bon ça c'est
non mais c'est pas moi c'est m nage du
père que j'ai vu à plusieurs reprises
alors sur la sphère castro la fausse
interview de fidel castro vous apporter
quoi comme un révélation bernard violet
jeu j'apporte mois de révélations que
des contradictions nouvelle fois chez
ppda parce que vous ardisson karl vous
avez démontré après avoir subi des
pressions pas possible vous souvenez
pour empêcher les filières de reportages
vous démontrer de façon magistrale le
mécanisme de ce bidonnage bon monsieur
bédié vingt ans après où un peu au bout
de 20 ans continue à nier l'évidence à
dire qu'il s'agissait pas d' abus de
nage et là c'est là que je comprends pas
et à nier quelques jours il nie les
évidences alors qu'on a des preuves les
faits des faits avérés vérifiées et
vérifiables
jeudi quelque chose qui tombe par honda
tête de ce titre et si c'est à lui qu'on
koffi la mission d'informer les français
tous les soirs je mens jusqu'à quel
point son information qui lui dit si
tous les soirs et fiable voyez c'est ça
que c'est si grave quelque part à mon
sens parce que je me demande c'est de
quel droit vous voudrez descendre morale
m'entendre je ne donne aucune zone
orageuse unis flics ni curé j'aligne des
faits
j'essaie d'apporter un sens aux attraits
de certaines grilles de lectures
historiques sociologiques ou voir pigrée
éthique c'est tout au lecteur de juger
au fil de ce qui a été dit y a rien de
nouveau sous le soleil ça méritait
vraiment pas un bouquin c'est défendre
la vie lui non ça ne change pas envie de
le lire si je ne vois pas l'intérêt de
ce livre très franchement si ça
démontre c'est d'abord ça explique le
destin exceptionnel c'est votre réussite
du tissu social exceptionnel mais au
pour lesquels on peut également se poser
des questions sur un homme dont la
charge quand même dit mission d'informer
tous les ya 10 millions de français si
cette information il dit la question se
pose pas de réponse dans ce genre de
beauté enchaîné lisez le d'abord et vous
verrez que moi tous les amis prestement
j'ai beaucoup mieux à faire que donnait
le soleil vous lisez ce que vous voulez
sur la sphère boutons par exemple
qu'est-ce que vous révéler de nouveaux
il ya un élément qui vont la faire beau
tôt
l'homme d'affaires donc lyonnais qui est
chargé de promouvoir la carrière de
michel noir dans fait du lobbying comme
on dit c'est notamment auprès de la
télévision parce qu'elle sait
d'athéniens cas plus d'impact on sait
comment ça s'est terminé ils achètent
beaucoup de journalistes un des voyages
exotiques des séjours à droite à gauche
un etc bon effectivement on reproche à
me reprocher un moment donné
pda d'avoir touché pour 2 millions de
francs de cadeaux de 100 millions de
centimes bon d'où procès eux
vous apporter de nouveau
cette affaire c'est l'histoire c'est
l'histoire d'un retournement de veste
nouveautés bd de pierre botton qui a
vraiment était prêt à tout balancer et
qui est par des mois où il a rencontré
ppda dans le bureau du juge
d'instruction courroye
qui se jette à son coût quasiment pierre
bon se dégonfle et ne livrera pas tous
les éléments qui la suppression à la
justice c'est bon ça c'est des mots
nouveaux skis et gallo illustre le
caractère être effectivement un peu un
peu plus tard presque
2ème épreuve et qui sait très bien ce
serait tellement tout ce que j'ai ma
place au gp e3 c'est que je sache oui
toutes les informations tous les élus
sont sourds s'est regroupé authentifiée
il ya plusieurs centaines de notes bon
donc je pense est beto si vous voulez
sur ce domaine bon là encore on peut
quand même se pose la question est-ce
qu'elle jeunesse qui reçoit pour des
milliers et les milliers de francs ou à
nous mettre de télévision qui reçoivent
les milliers de francs ou des motards 50
mille francs de temps en temps son roman
en deux temps dans leur travail moi je
pense pas personnellement bien est-ce
que ce métier c'est aussi une certaine
éthique bien alors sur les rapports sur
les rapports de poivre d'arvor avec la
presse people
vous apporter quoi de nouveau dans votre
bouquin bernard là aussi je souligne
cette façon de ppda d'instrumentaliser
la presse people je
m'attendais s'est sauvé la mise de terre
shahzad qui allait être éjecté après le
retard de son mari procure plus bon
évidemment au créneau médiatique bon
fait la couverture de paris match
toujours pour défendre sa consoeur bon
quand il a des problèmes de coeur ou des
valeurs bon il s'expose à david et après
il va se poser en poseur de
virtualisation tout j'ai pas vu privé
afin de savoir je sois au jour je
n'entendais tout soit pour quoi au soir
au se poser également encore des
questions légitimes pourquoi j'ai vu pda
existe-t-il bâti besoin d'exhiber sa vie
privée ses personnages jusqu'à son gamin
aujourd'hui vous vous comprenez bien
remarqué que là tout ce que vous nous
dites c'est de l'opinion dit cela je
démonte les mécanismes
l'opinion c'est l'électeur qui l'auront
moi je donne j'apporte des faits je
démonte les mécanismes des ressorts
d'une façon d'agir bon de se comporter
et puis pour peut-être expliquer aux
fins du compte que on était un peu cocu
tous testés terre citoyens avec ce genre
de personnages qui essaient de faire la
plus développée c'est le pouvoir quand
même il n'est pas aux îles comme au sein
de la galaxie médiatique en france et
partout le jt les émissions littéraires
les radios la presse écrite je dire
celle de poids si vous verriez les
pressions ou la peur des gens j'ai
rencontré un bruit notamment pour des
des deux otages voudrait bien d'aider
les 102 lits des dizaines d'auteurs bon
à qui je faisais question bon comment ça
se passe avec ppda poivre
d'arvor vous a pas interdit de
rencontrer des gens il a pas appelé des
gens en leur disant de ne pas vous
rencontrez non à ça je reconnais que bon
lui a refusé de collaborer mais il m'a
laissé après y'a pas verrouillée qui m'a
fait recevoir par certains membres de sa
famille ses meilleurs amis ça lorsque
les femmes étant au dessus de savoir qui
est le début puis de travail enfin cela
étant bon le mauvais coup qui met à
jouer en sortant son bouquin avant le
mien pour parasiter la sortie de la bio
c'est bon c'est parce que ces digues ont
cédé
mais oui salariale et n'a jamais donné
sa version et c'est normal bon il se
doute bien que vous avez dans votre
bouquin d'après la journaliste s'était
révélé l'existence de l'enfant qu'il
était claire chazal il sort un bouquin
15 aux avants avec serge raffy quai
numéro un des ventes d'ailleurs et
qu'est-ce qui fait il balance avant vous
c'est normal vous a coupé l'herbe sous
le pied mais c'est un accord parce que
je veux dire que et les jo d'été les
canchas fait l'élégance là dedans à
chaque fois que j'ai collaboré soit kbp
yao johnny cd travail est passé on
attend dé lui c'est son fils est normal
qu'ils veulent plus chine elle vous
savez très bien toujours été au courant
vous dans le micro par la crise espère
en fait 2 et illimité dit-il en arrière
les airs note il fait ici guerre parce
que c'est tout à fait absurde pied sans
soirée françois figure dans le 12 août
2003 ouais ok il ya un bon side mais
quand même j'ai ouvert parce qu'on va
couper l'herbe sous le pied quoi non
réchou sa part très dénigrants schultz à
une roublardise
de court circuiter les bouquins à
s'enlever
fait ce qu'il est mais c'est bon c'est
pas très sympa participons tous oui
enfin bon je pense que les lecteurs se
prépare on retient plus plus le seront
vers les rangs de matières de matière
dans mon bouquin que donc ce jeu vous
dire un truc un clic come back et vous
vous croyez pas qu'on lui fait cousteau
par exemple à vous apprenez la voix
demande et le fond là non
quand vous faites cousteau vous apprenez
vraiment des trucs sur plus tôt c'est à
dire cette dimension collaborationniste
mais sur ppda franchement tout a été dit
il ya d'autres beaucoup d'autres il est
dit ceci la prochaine victime d'un petit
mais non mais là là avec le mauvais tour
joué les coups de jarnac images ou et ça
décourage de jouer la transparence mais
désire vous je vais le dire parce que
notre ami
ben c'est pas une victime ça sera un
héros pour moi ces héros c'est pas des
victimes et donc vos prochaines héros
sera dommage que le jumeau de sa poule a
sera un monument du cinéma français qui
était gérard depardieu
avait révélé qu'il boit
non
c'est publié chez flammarion et les
messieurs et pour être sûr de ne rien
rater de in a l'habitude abonnez vous il
m'était impossible eux